(dramatic piano music)
- I've been called all
kinds of things, Casper,
Snow White, ugly, (light chuckling)
just all kinds of mean, terrible things.
People have said that I
wouldn't make it as a model,
but I am a model.
(hip-hop music)
I'm Diandra Forrest,
I was one of the first
models with albinism
signed to a major modeling agency.
Albinism is a gene that
causes lack of pigment
in hair, skin, and eyes.
I grew up in the Bronx,
so there's a lot of either
blacks or Hispanics.
People were always like,
"What are you?," you know.
I'd be like, "Yeah, I'm
black or African American,"
and it’s like, "No, you're not."
I'm just, "Okay, how are you
gonna tell me what I am?"
Rain is my daughter, my
eight-week now old daughter.
We're a very blended
family, (light laughing)
when it comes to skin color.
Black comes in all shades,
so we're just adding more
complexions to my family.
(light piano music)
I walked the runaway with
Rain during Fashion Week
and she slept the whole time.
I want her to grow up to be,
you know, her own person,
not afraid to ask
questions, know who she is
and be interested to know
who other people are as well.
(light piano music)
I didn't always feel beautiful.
Words do hurt, you know.
I am bothered by things people say,
but, you know there's beauty in everybody
and I think it should be celebrated.
Once you feel the confidence
and know who you are as a person,
it can't really affect you anymore.